la menace de fermeture des trois
alumineries d'alcoa au québec est
maintenant à écarter la multinationale
refusé je vous le rappelle les hausses
de tarifs demandée par hydro québec le
gouvernement marois donc négocier une
nouvelle entente
hervé gaudreault explique mille emplois
directs et indirects menacés avec une
élection qui approche on a mené pauline
marois à protéger ses acquis économiques
je suis particulièrement fier de la
conclusion de cette entente qui marque
un nouveau départ dans notre relation
avec alcoa
en plus d'assurer la pérennité de ses
activités au québec et le maintien
d'emplois de qualité dans nos régions
en contrepartie alcoa va investir 250
millions de dollars en cinq ans pour
rendre ces aluminerie de deschambault
bécancour et baie comeau plus
performantes
l'aluminerie de baie-comeau va produire
des alliages pour l'industrie automobile
et peut-être pour mes batteries
révolutionnaire destiné à des voitures
électriques avec les constructeurs
automobiles un gros marché qui va
s'ouvrir pour l'aluminium et je crois
que on pourra ce moment-là avoir des
perspectives beaucoup plus importante en
termes de modernisation mais
l'investissement de plus d'un milliard
de dollars pour la modernisation de
l'aluminerie de baie-comeau déjà reporté
trois fois et relégué aux oubliettes la
modernisation et blé plus dans les
cartons à ce moment on s'est donné un
plan de match pour assurer la pérennité
de l'usiné de baie-comeau le choix qui a
été fait c'est de dire comment maintenir
le niveau d'emploi et c'est ce qu'on
annonce aujourd'hui un maintien du
niveau d'emploi
la coalition aluminium manicouagan
reçoit l'entente comme un prix de
consolation
oui oui mais je vais attendre des
réponses comme moi il ya quand même des
réalités qu'on avec leur projet de budan
elle court là dessus il y avait une
sécurité qui est qui planait sur baie
comeau depuis quelques mots et ça
devient lourd pour ça ça vient de l'eau
pour les familles al qoura à supprimer
700 emplois à baie comeau
depuis 2008 ici hervé gaudreault
radio-canada à baie comeau
sébastien bovet donc y avait du chantage
dans le comportement d' alcoa devant
nous on plie bagage si vous ne baissez
pas les tarifs le chantage à fonctionner
quoi oui on peut pas peut-être pas dire
que le gouvernement a plié devant la
menace mais certainement qu'il a été
très conciliant et l écoute d'alcoa
parce que après tout le gouvernement
avait une entente signée en bonne et due
forme pour augmenter les tarifs
d'électricité sauf que cette menace l'a
fait en sorte que 3000 jobs était
menacée que le québec peut pas se
permettre ni même 3000 job que aussi
d'un secteur industriel on peut pas se
permettre de perdre un gros joueur est à
première vue l'entente semble assez
gagnant gagnant c'est à dire que le prix
de l'électricité modulée selon le prix
de l'aluminé l'aluminium sur le marché
international mais quand même eu un
contexte électoral à cette annonce
baie comeau et dans une circonscription
péquiste mais deschambault effet
bécancour sont déjà dans des
circonscriptions caquistes voyait
peut-être là aussi un calcul de la part
de madame marois
mais c'est fou comme des poils passé
ressemble au présent je me rappelle
qu'en mars 2003 bernard landry était
allé à deschambault annoncé
l'agrandissement de lusine il avait dit
quand on a un bon gouvernement on le
garde c'était une semaine avant de
déclencher des élections pour le 14
avril
vous savez ce qui s'est passé dans
portneuf où des chambres est situé ce
candidat libéral qui avait été lui donc
morale de l'histoire il n'y a pas de
garantie quand on fait ce genre d'
annonce en pré campagne est le cas vous
nous parler de la campagne électorale le
tableau se précise à propos des
candidats
oui nous avons appris que françois
gendron le vice premier ministre le
doyen de l'assemblée nationale va
solliciter un onzième mandat 11 mandats
il fera l'annoncé demain après midi et
il ya une anecdote numérologique pour
monsieur
gendron le 14 avril ça va faire 13 mille
six cent soixante quatre jours qu'il est
député eelv a égalé le record de gérard
des lévesque le 14 avril
s'il remporte l'élection du 14 et une
élection le 14
il deviendra recorman le lendemain le 15
avril
cela étant dit djemila benhabib pourrait
bien sollicité la candidature du parti
québécois dans mille îles
c'est ce que rapporte l'écho de laval
mom invite à la prudence sur cette
candidature en disant que tout l'édifice
ils joueront pas encore attachés mais
certainement de l'intérêt et lorraine
pintal directrice générale du théâtre du
nouveau monde à montréal sera la
candidate du parti québécois dans verdun
le pq pense pouvoir battre
henri-françois gautrin qui a gagné par
environ 550 bottes à la dernière
élection madame benhabib qui s'étaient
présentés dans trois rivières grands qui
elle même ne se représente pas pour les
libéraux je sens que j'ai 14 sébastien
nous allons passer la soirée ensemble
absolument avec plaisir salut barrière
de ma voix